the thing is you have this big coaching
base of people you could continue to
scale it and just keep scaling it it's
very difficult to run two at the same
time like a southern business is totally
different or a licensing business which
is B2B is totally different if I were in
your shoes I would just be like why
can't I 10x this and get to 100 million
there's all these problems that are
confronting you to do that and they're
probably hard problems but those are the
ones you have to solve and like the
price tag for that answer is 100 million
so it's like well of course they're hard
to solve that's why it's 100 million
dollars but if you solve it you get to